we're talking about donuts
um not these kind of donuts obviously
but um donut shaped planets that's what
we're going to talk about can we imagine
that you could have a planet that was
shaped literally like this like a ring
you know physically it is possible yeah
the laws of physics permit you to have a
a donut shape like this so what what do
you need to have such a configuration
basically you need the the object to be
spinning okay so it needs to be spinning
why if it's not spinning then it's just
going to collapse under under its own
gravity so you need that that
centrifugal force to push outwards if
you spin it too much basically all the
material will just sort of be shot out
into space but if you get it just right
in principle you could get a planet
shape like this it's a very difficult
configuration to sort of engineer
whether it's going to happen naturally
is another matter but maybe some sort of
elong musk type uh alien innovator could
uh you know sort of for whatever reason
it's a big stunt create one but within
laws of physics it is allowed to have
such a configurator you just need that
centrifugal force to push you out you
could even start with a like an
ellipsoid type type
planet and spin it in the right way and
get the the the doughnut to form
again it would be something you'd have
to do very precisely it wouldn't just
happen you know you knock it at all and
it's going to destroy it but if you get
it right you can get get something like
this to form and it would actually be
roughly stable in the sense that you
know you spin it up a little bit more
it's not going to destroy it spin it
down a little bit it's not going to
destroy it where it is vulnerable is to
things like tidal forces so this is you
know much more stretched out than an
ordinary planet you know we think it's
orbiting some star then the difference
between sort of the force here and the
force here could cause it to break up so
this is the kind of instability that it
would be vulnerable to that actually
affects where you might want to put one
of these things you don't want it to put
it too close to the star because it will
break up for that reason because of the
tidal forces but of course if you want
to live on this thing
you've got to be near enough to the star
to sort of get all the heat and stuff so
actually if such a thing were to exist
you'd probably want it in the vicinity
of a bright star uh that way you could
be far away but you know sort of getting
enough energy from from the starters to
sort of support life on it
so it's interesting to think about what
some of the you know features would be
would be like on on this this this crazy
object a lot of it depends on the tilt
so for example if it had zero tilt
relative to the plane of its orbit the
really interesting stuff would happen on
this
interior ring you'd basically get no
light on the interior at all ever
until it would be in a really cold
dark desolate place the water would be
frozen copper ducks would be frozen it
would be quite a horrendous place
whereas out here it would be perfectly
nice and of course there'd be different
you know temperature differences which
could lead to some extreme weather but
but overall it you know over here it'd
be quite nice over here it'd be not very
nice the other feature about it is to
think about is the um
you know where what the gravitational
distribution is you would always sort of
fall inwards you know into the object
the gravity would always point into the
object there's no lateral flow that
basically makes sense because it's a
surface of equal potential it has to be
but where is the gravity least where is
it strongest so if you imagine an object
which was say the mass of the earth and
was spun up to the right rate what you
would find is that this this region
would be a bit flatter than in this case
the gravity would be weakest here and in
an interior it'd be quite weak here
maybe maybe a third of earth's gravity
and the reason for that is just because
right in here you've got the pull of the
other side pulling you in the wrong
direction and here you've got the sort
of large centrifugal effects especially
the gravity would be strongest here
still less than earth's gravity but the
weakest gravitational regions would be
here and here tony i thought the center
of gravity would be in the middle there
and if you were living in here you'd be
sucked into the middle so certainly if
you if you're far away
then you that's what you'd experience
right but if you're within the object
you sort of feel the distribution a bit
more and and indeed the dominant effect
of you around here would be this mass
here okay that's not to say you don't
feel this region you do
and that's why for example the gravity
is weak here
but it but yeah the dominant effect
clearly comes to here and that's how it
holds together it has to be like that
otherwise it wouldn't even hold together
people living on the inside of the ring
aren't being sucked up into space no the
main force would be that way but they
would have competing effects pulling
them that way which is why the gravity
feels weak
what if it was tilted like the earth
like 23 degree tilt you would now get
some light in the interior okay there
would be some light in the interior
particularly on the equator what you
would find is in the summer in the
winter you would have ordinary days
they'd be very short
because this thing's rotating very
quickly it'd probably rotate within a
few hours
okay so you have very short days but but
nevertheless you'd get days and nights
because you would get that cycle of
light
if you were
slightly in some sort of you know region
further north or further south
then you would be a bit like the sort of
polar regions here you'd get like a
period of six months without sun you
know and it would be like that basically
very similar to the polar regions
because of that difference in how much
energy these areas received again you
would have quite sharp temperature
differences maybe some extreme weather
um associated with that there's also
some quite interesting plate tectonics
could occur as well so you might ask
well would you even have plate tectonics
and naively might say not right because
you know this this has a very large
surface area compared to like a
spherical planet for example you know
compared to its volume so you might
think it's going to lose a lot of its
thermal energy and therefore you
wouldn't have the volcanism inside the
the uh you know inside this object
but again you've got the tidal forces
which which it feels more of so that
might that might liven things up a
little bit so this possibility could
have could have some plate tectonics and
then you get some really weird stuff
going on and again the exciting place is
this interior this is where all the fun
and games happens one thing you'll
notice is you take a region here so
imagine a plate like a tectonic plate
has a certain size here and it fits
quite nicely into that ring there it's
that area but the ring on the outside is
much bigger than the ring on the inside
so if you try to push this plate inwards
it's not got enough space what's going
to happen folding you're going to get
crazy mountain ranges in here right and
you'll also get rifts as they move away
as as plates try to move out of that
region it's not big enough to fill the
space they go into so you get rift so
you get mounted you get rich you have
great geological structures in here the
grandest of grand canyons yeah and the
other thing to remember of course is is
the gravity is weaker as well right so
the mounds are going to be higher so not
only do you gonna get amounts because
things get you know squashing into here
but they're going to be higher as well
maybe three times higher if it's a third
of the gravity
yeah there's there's all sorts of crazy
effects that you would get here you'd
get like very high waves why would
highways well of course once again
because of the weaker gravity so you'll
get larger waves perhaps three times
higher you get high clouds for the same
reason there's quite an exotic region
inside that interior i think compared to
maybe the rest of the planet uh so it's
quite fun
tony we live in this almost infinite
universe that you've talked about with
us before do you think one of these is
formed somewhere
see obviously it's a great question
um
one like this with a with a great hole
in the middle
well i mean is the universe infinite it
might even be donut shaped of course
this is it infinite um if it's infinite
then you might enter the
might be a possibility i think like i
said before it's probably something that
you would have to artificially create
with some fancy technology but what is
interesting and what could exist and
probably
does does exist and our earth may have
even been shaped like this in the past
it's not quite a doughnut like this
but a doughnut with the jam in the
middle this is as i said i was
describing it to my kids and that's what
they said they said oh it's like a
doughnut with the jam in the middle so
what i mean by that is is you've got
this sort of donut structure on the
outside but there's there's an interior
region as well so the overall shape is
still but don't lie but it's like an
interior region which is which is there
as well like the jam is essentially
which is connected it's actually got a
name it's called a synestia it's only
something that's apparently so far has
appeared in simulations in particular by
i think it's simon locke and sarah
stewart who are two
physicists working in america what they
showed was they were doing some
simulations of the early solar system
for example and they showed that when
two objects you know two sort of
planet-sized objects collide then
there's a possibility of forming one of
these these synesthesias so you have the
two planet-sized objects they come in
together it's extremely generally a lot
of heat so they can essentially vaporize
all the rock and at the same time they
can come in with a lot of angular
momentum and that angular momentum is
going to combine and it's going to cause
them to spin faster it's just like
bringing two skaters together right
you've got two skaters they're spinning
if they come together then they're going
to combine their own momentum and if
they tuck in they'll spin faster and
faster and faster so you have this
situation where two planets come in
smashing together heat everything up
vaporize everything and it's spinning
like crazy
okay what happens
so in that configuration which is quite
a possible configuration
you find that you get this this rapidly
spinning region in the interior
okay and you might say and it's spinning
like crazy and you say well well let's
look at the gas on the on the outer edge
how fast is that spinning
it's spinning very quickly
in fact it's spinning too quickly in
principle so what you'd say is is it
spinning faster than say a satellite
that would be at the same point so you
know if you take a satellite in orbit
around the planet you can say you can
work out how fast it's spinning how fast
it's it's it's it's going how fast it's
going around orbiting yeah half-assing
orbiting yeah you can work out you can
work out its speed as a particular speed
based on its altitude
okay
and if you bring that that satellite in
towards the edge of the edge of the
planet it'll have a particular speed
that's characteristic of how high it is
if you compare that speed
to the speed of the edge bit of gas if
the edge bit of gas is going faster
that's a completely inconsistent
configuration you can't have that it
should shoot off it needs to spread out
absolutely exactly right pretty it needs
to spread out and that's what happens
this is how the synesthete forms the
object that you create in the impact is
trying to spin too quickly
okay so it needs to spread out its outer
gas and it can do it because it's all
gaseous so it spreads itself out and it
forms this donut shape so what you have
is this inner rotating core spinning
like mud and you have this gas
large gas gauge you know vaporized
objects spread out okay it looks like a
doughnut as i said it's called a
sinestria uh sin means sort of you know
together the the the ester part comes
from the greek goddess hestia which is
the goddess of structure so it's like
this sort of together structure you've
got the inner core connected to the to
this outer doughnut like like object
and there's there's good reason to
believe that this our earth might have
had a period of synesthetic phase
maybe for a few hundred years very early
on oh that shorter time
yeah it's very quick yeah it doesn't say
yeah yeah so it doesn't last very long
and the reason is because the object
cools so as it cools it starts to shrink
okay so so yeah so it's a temporary
phase
now you could in principle have such an
object near a very hot star
it remains vaporized it's spinning then
it could be a synesthete so we could
look for sonestas very close to stars
but there's good reason to believe the
earth did spend some time
as a synesthete and the reason is it can
explain some quirky features of how the
moon was formed one of the puzzles about
the moon is uh is its content so we know
that it has a lot of its makeup is very
similar to what we see on earth which
suggests they have a common origin
okay and the usual theory is that you
know a mars-sized planet i think it's
called thea comes crashing into earth
and then the moon sort of spilled it
came came from that
but one of the slightly subtle things
about this is is that there are elements
on earth which are sort of less abundant
on the moon okay some of the more
volatile stuff stuff like potassium and
sodium it's not it's just not as common
on the moon so why a bit of a mystery
senescence can explain it and the way
they explain it is you have this
collision semester forms in the very
early earth rates this is great and then
and then inside the cenestia there's a
little bit of the molten rock
which kind of forms the seed from the
for a proto moon
okay and it sort of gathers around it
and then the sinestro starts to cool now
everything's vaporized at this point
so the more volatile space price and the
less volatile stuff is vaporized as the
senestia cools the less volatile stuff
stuff like silicon starts to sort of
essentially
rain down
on the objects so it rains down on the
proto moon it rains down on the central
core but it's raining silicon on this
moon building the moon up but it's it's
putting the less volatile stuff on there
right the silicons and the aluminiums
and things like that then it cools so
some more the synestia falls in takes
with it all the more volatile stuff that
isn't ready to rain down on the proto
moon yet
leaves the moon behind
without any of that volatile stuff and
everything else cools over time and
falls back into the earth and explains
the the difference so this is one of the
ideas for how the moon was formed uh
from basically donuts in the in the
early solar system
so the earth that was a donut maybe
can i tell you about a new number
so it's a very scary number it's a bit
evil it's um belfigures prime okay so
belfica one of the seven princes of hell
so black hole will eventually radiate
eventually give off a type of radiation
called hawking radiation right now this
is what you get when you apply quantum
mechanics to the event horizon of a
black hole